alors donc le samedi soir terminé ah ben
oui le samedi soir ce serait jeu sera un
week end serait en normandie regardez la
nouvelle émission de léa salamé ou pas
je ne vais pas mentir sûrement que j'ai
rien si je suis chez moi je suis invitée
chez des biens la maison si je suis
habité chez des amis s'il ya du foot je
peux peut-être regarder le foot c'est
tout un tas et là ça passera à mon avis
tardivement et non mais il ya des
chances que je regarde par curiosité
évidemment je vais perdre entre comment
laurent c'est vrai qu'on voit là je te
pose la question c'est vrai qu'on a on
est tous tombés de notre chaise quand on
quand j'ai vu que tu n'étais plus le
samedi soir on s'y croyait pas ses yeux
franchement gros et je croyais pas cela
même quand je t'ai appelé j'ai appelé
jeudi mais je pense que c'est une
connerie et je pense que laurent ibars
prendre le samedi soir donc je l'appelle
pour rien mais ça me fait plaisir de
boire inversée mais c'est ma décision
ouais j'aurais pu être le samedi soir de
la saison prochaine au musée plus en duo
avec léa salamé mais je ne m'amusais
plus cher aussi que ça fait des années
on n'est pas propriétaire d'une casse ça
fait plus de 15 ans 17 ans avec les deux
années donné en direct que je suis là et
samedi soir c'est bien aussi de faire
autre chose si j'avais été seul j'aurais
sûrement continuer mais serré cordiaux
un talk show c'est difficile à animer
j'ai préféré à voile avant d importance
que tu dis moi je te dis franchement
laurent jeu je suis je me suis dis
franchement de laurence et la classe
absolue l'année dernière quand on t'a
dit on va te mettre le dr salem à côté
de toi je te dis franchement j'aime bien
le aléas je trouve qu'elle fait leur
boulot mais moi je dit souvent que deux
numéros 1 1 feront jamais un très bon
numéro un parce que c'est ça sert à rien
en fait il faut mettre tout seul tu l'a
fait pendant des années et les alors
elle peut avoir une autre émission elle
le fait très bien aussi mais c'est vrai
que je me suis dit comment laurent a
accepté c'est comme si moi on me disait
on va te mettre valérie bénaïm à tes
côtés et c'est vrai que je serais très
content parce qu'elle est très jolie
vous l'avez pas dit encore
une bombe l'honneur et d'un mais c'est
vrai laurent c'est la classe franchement
tag nommé d'abord parce que j'avais déjà
travaillé avec léa salamé que j'avais
déjà eu
léa le dit souvent dans les interviews
elle ne ment pas c'est vrai j'avais déjà
eu cette idée de faire un duo mais
c'était une idée plus plus anciennes
j'en avais plus l'idée je vais être
honnête aussi la dernière où il ya deux
ans j'étais très bien tout seul à
sourire préféré continuer à faire
l'émission tout seul mais comme j'avais
émis cette idée à l'époque dont on n'est
pas couché quand les gars étaient encore
avec moi pour ben voila j'ai j'ai
accepté d'essayer j'ai essayé ça ma
moitié plus mais quand ça me plaît à
moitié je préfère m'en aller mais après
coup vous regrettez du coup dur à
accepter ah ben oui forcément oui force
et à qui on regrette d'avoir accepté oui
c'est vrai je vais être honnête femme
merci beaucoup à bail il faut ces bonnes
questions ils sont pas payés à rien
[ __ ] tu connais les chroniqueurs s et
du rhin de 2,2 de choisir les
chroniqueurs oui mais là je crois que
ronald à voilà moi j'ai pris les moins
chers
tu es content alors on à la crème de la
crème
ce soir pour ce jeune femme que je
connais moi alors c'est daniel moreau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je
regarde bassam al qahtani n'était pas là
ce soir je suis ainsi parce qu'il a vu
cet été mais il a une poitrine excite